this is a production of Cornell
University
I'm very excited to be here I'm also a
little uneasy because as Kevin mentioned
I am very broad broadly trained macro
Ecology's sometimes I think I'm a
conservation biologist definitely not a
plant scientist so bear with me some
some information may be spotty in terms
of maybe what is the core interest for
you so to put to put my presentation in
perspective it's all about new ways to
study or investigate an old questions an
old question where why our species
distributed or found where they are and
I'd like to start with with an inspiring
quote that pushes biologists or at least
in 1985 in Wilson was pushing biologists
to to take on this grand challenge of
trying to describe and trying to to
learn more about about diversity in
general worldwide so in the words of yo
Wilson this is a mission worth all our
effort so that was 1985 not too long ago
then in 2010 another great entomologist
came back to tell us that it is critical
it is very important to try to study
diversity on our planet and maybe what
we need is a grand approach the type of
approach and the type of funding and
resources that nASA has so you know some
years ago 15 years after yo Wilson
called all scientists to study diversity
and focus on that 15 years later the
message was very similar or even
stronger now
another approach another message that is
related to trying to understand trying
to study diversity and and basically
provide a justification for
this effort is from the from the world
of ecosystem science and valuation of
ecosystem services so the idea here is
we do want to know as much as we can
about species and it is worth investing
our time because our understanding of
species distribution and function and
ecosystems actually in the end overall
affect human life quality so so
basically put a spin to our type of
research that that makes the public more
interested and more aware of why we
study diversity patterns okay
just to give you a very brief schematic
view of what I do and then a a cloud of
words that are more common or abundant
in in my publication so far I am as I
said broadly speaking interested in
interested in species distributions and
factors that affect species
distributions and I use several ways of
addressing questions that are related to
species distributions and then the
understanding our understanding of
species distributions does branch out
into many different fields and I'm just
naming a few here conservation biology
biogeography and this is ecology the
more recent ones okay so what I want to
do today is give you an idea of the kind
of work that I do and maybe spark some
interest in your using some of these
methods for your your own research and
my plan is to go down a spacial scale
from broad scale questions to may be
regional all the way to find scale
you'll notice that I have one here the
last the final final scale question in
gray area gray font and that is because
we are just starting to work more on
this at this level on the scale and we
have more questions and more data to
call
and analyze them actually giving you
answers okay now to in order to address
questions at these various scales
questions related to distribution and
factors that affect species
distributions I'm using two main types
of research of techniques one is
ecological niche modeling and the other
one is remote sensing so I'll give you
brief very brief overviews on the two as
we go down the scale to these two see
these examples these are plant examples
as I said they may not be very dense and
informatively
informative but from a biological
standpoint but hopefully you can help me
fill in the blanks in those areas okay
so ecological niche modeling or enm is a
very active field of research but what I
wanted to do first is start with just an
understanding of the terminology because
we know that niche can mean various
things to various people so you may be
aware of the over the echo out the
history of ecology you may be aware of
definitions of niche provided by
Grinnell in the early nineteen hundred's
Alton in the 1930s and then hutchinson
in the nineteen fifties and sixties so
what how do we make sense of all these
definitions well to me it makes sense
and to other people it makes sense to
think of the effects that organisms have
on environments on the environments that
they occupy versus the responses that
organisms have to the environment and
the the kinds of requirements that
organisms have where how they choose
environments in which day they live and
survive okay so if we think about the
niche from from this effects versus
responses or impacts of species on the
environment versus requirements
environmental requirements of species
maybe it's a little easier to make sense
of these definitions okay and then
trying to put the the niche concepts on
a geographic scale we can think of
questions that are addressed that small
scale extends geographic extent versus
large geographic extent and on this
sliding scale going back to impacts
versus requirements think about that the
small geographic extent when we talk
about species impacts what we are
talking about is the functional role of
species in that in that that small scale
and for these kinds of questions we
usually use mechanistic mister
mechanistic models that try to quantify
the dynamic relationships between
between species think think think of
consumer resource dynamics so those are
very different models than what what I
do which is at larger extents and
ecological niche modeling is more useful
at these larger extents I should point
over here where the interest is in the
requirements that species have in order
to survive in a certain region so that
summarizes the geographic niche or the
abiotic niche of species and to do that
we use empirical models and I'll show
you one type of models that we used in
this broad umbrella of ecological niche
modeling and the big assumption here is
that the requirements the environmental
requirements of the species are stronger
than the interactions the biotic
interactions so basically the abiotic
interactions are more important than
biotic interactions in shaping the
distribution of species at these larger
scales okay so how do we go about if we
are into the ecological niche modeling
field how do we go about measuring
estimating
I'm defying this abiotic on all
grinnellian each as it is known in the
literature well there are three methods
that I'm aware of or three possible
approach approaches one would be
physiological experiments so we go in
the lab and we test the limits that a
species has an organism has two let's
say varying temperature if it's an
aquatic species varying salinity so on
so forth so we go into the lab and we
find out what are the physiological
boundaries of the species which can then
possibly be mapped on geography this is
really hard work to do and if we are
interested in mapping the biodiversity
of a little study of a study that has
not been over country that has not been
studied very well we do not have time to
develop physiological models for many
different species for which we don't
have information then slightly maybe mad
scientist scenario would be to introduce
species in various types of environments
and figure out which kinds of
environments sustain allow that species
to survive in long term this is
obviously impractical a large large
scale probably unethical we don't want
to change ecosystems by doing these
kinds of large-scale studies into the
introducing species so the third method
that is widely used in ecological niche
modeling world is has to do with making
use of information we have available
about where species are and the
environmental conditions that are
present at those locations so we build
correlation type models simply put that
quantified that relationship between
where species are and what kind of
environments are present at those
locations and just to give you a more
visual on the these correlation
approaches to estimate environmental
requirements we start with
this is records this could be museum
specimens this these could be surveys
any type of occurrence data then we on
top of that we use various digitized
maps of environmental conditions and I'm
showing you just some examples here
precipitation annual precipitation
annual temperature seasonality of
precipitation and temperature so on so
forth and then these form our
calibration data or training data which
we use to build a model estimate the
niche of that species and there is a
plethora of algorithms and approaches to
making sense quantifying this
relationship between organism presence
and environment I'm naming just a few
here and I'll briefly mention show Max n
okay jump on so once we have that once
we have the model calibrated with these
occurrences and environmental data what
we do is we then project this model back
on to geography so we take we take data
out of the geographic context the
spatial context in this environmental
context we build a model we calibrate
the model and then we take that model
back into geography we project that
model and I get back to why this is
important this model projection but what
we get is an estimation of suitability
across the landscape for that particular
species of interest and I need to move a
lot faster okay so one of the widely
used algorithms is MaxEnt this the the
paper that was that promoted the use of
Max and or described this algorithm was
published in 2006 it has been cited over
3,000 times now it is a widely used
methodology what we do here is basically
contrast known presences with the rest
of the environment so we have some
occurrences we have some knowledge of
our species is present in
on a landscape and we contrast the
conditions at presences with the
conditions at across the rest of the
landscape and that's one way of of
quantifying suitability we get a
probability of suitability more likely
if the the conditions are similar to
presences and less likely if the
conditions are similar to the rest of
the background so it's contrasting
presence and the rest of the environment
okay
so jumping to the first example of the
use of Nikhil ecological niche modeling
I put this up the largest scale but you
see that we actually varied the scale of
the question for this for this project
and the idea was can we create reliable
species richness estimates when we are
dealing with various geographic extent
or the scale of our analysis varies and
this is an area of intense research
because we use these estimated species
with richness maps to create for example
hotspots for conservation or for future
climate effect so on so forth so knowing
how well we estimate species richness
with ecological niche modeling is of
importance for various reasons okay so
the question is do we do we get various
estimates in terms of quality various
species reached richness estimates from
ecological niche modeling when the scale
varies so that that was the question
that we tried to answer Ajay Harris is
not a PhD candidate anymore she she
successfully defended about two weeks
ago so she's moving on to a postdoc here
at the Smithsonian but she was the main
driver of this particular study and then
her advisor dr. Mike Palmer both from
the botany department
at Oklahoma State and we are working the
journal the the manuscript is in review
hopefully we'll have positive criticism
and useful reviews back soon ok so what
was the idea here the idea was to
compare correlate observed species
richness with estimated species richness
so the observed species richness these
data come from Flores and the estimated
species richness the data come from
stacked models so we build we build
basically sorry I'll talk about the
models later but ok so what is the
observed species richness our this is
what we considered the standard in this
study so using a large amount of data
from various Flora's that a lot of data
came from the Flora's of North America
project but also from check lists and
very small scale Flora's across North
America we well AJ mostly AJ amassed a
data set of Jack tasty and financing
species in North America north of Mexico
so excluding Mexico we didn't have data
in for for Mexico so what you see are at
the county level but the Flores had
different scales but at the county level
you see the species richness the number
of species in these two families that we
decided to compare okay and then based
on the information that we had about the
florist
we created six classes of expense or
Flores that were generated at six
different extents starting from Penn
hectare between ten hectare and 100
hectares all the way to a million to 10
million hectares and we try to have a
very well-balanced data set we
split the the flora information in the
three regions Arctic Atlantic and
Pacific and we had in each class scale
class we had the same number of Flora's
that we considered for this study okay
and then for the estimated species
richness we apply the collage ecology
modeling species by species we build
models for for the cactus II and pine AC
with the same occurrence data
environmental data approach max an
ecological niche modeling algorithm and
we created these predictive
distributions for each species which
then we stacked for each flora okay so
what did we get
oh sorry and I forgot to mention we had
24 species of cactus II and 50 ones this
is your finest most of the data for the
ecological niche modeling prod part of
this project came from the global
biodiversity information facility which
is a distributed database of Museum
records and observation and then we had
as environmental data or variables we
had climatic data and soil data for this
project okay so we generate these fact
models to estimate the number of species
in each flora we considered at these six
different scales so then we put the two
together and we try to to see how well
they correlate okay starting with cacti
see what we see is that if we pull all
extents those six or eight different
extents we have if we pull them together
we get a good correlation I would say
0.68 deviation from the from the slope
of one quite big so it is okay it's an
OK correlation not not a very strong
correlation so coalition between of
observes disease richness through flora
and estimated species richness through
this stacking of ecological niche models
but when we start separating by by
extents of Flora's what we see is at the
largest extent
one to ten million hectares we have a
high correlation so at the largest
extent this seems to be a useful
approach now on the other end of the
spectrum at the finest extent abysmal
let's not do this let's not use the
ecological niche morning and the stacked
approach to estimate species richness
because it's not really doing do it
we finally see the situation is not good
at all so at all extents definitely not
not working at the largest extent
somewhat working there is the
correlation is 0.56 somewhat okay but
not not a great approach the slope the
deviation from the slope is not is
better when we go to the smallest extent
as you expected do not do this let's not
do this let's not estimate species
richness with stacked with the stacked
ecologic on each morning approach okay
so that was one way of informing the
psychological niche modeling field of
the applicability of this approach to
estimating species richness next what I
want to do is go into a slightly smaller
scale and talk about climatic niche
dissimilarity for one plant species that
has two morphs
so the question here was do we see a
climatic difference between populations
that have different morphologies and
this study is a collaboration with
botanist again from a botanist from
genetics from OSU then Donna from Diana
and now P from University of Alaska
Fairbanks and then geologist from from
OSU so what we did here is not me but
Jeannette examined two morphs of Arab
adopts this Kamchatka and she used the
herbarium specimens
available
at at the University of Alaska so the
two morphs that she looked at and that
are common in in Kamchatka populations
are the the type try comparing leads
versus glabrous leaves so smooth versus
leads that have that have these
unicellular trichomes
so she was able to find 116 specimens
for the try comparing morph and 203 30
specimens for the glabrous more and this
is a map of the distribution of these of
the specimens she geo-reference
she and Jeff geo-reference many of these
occurrences okay so what did we do with
this we took the records for the to
morphs environmental data again and we
we build two models two different models
for the try comparing specimens based on
the try comparing specimens specimens
and the glabrous specimens so what we
what we see is first look at these maps
is the tri cone bearing has a narrower
distribution than the glabrous i'm sorry
yes yes exactly this is more coastal and
this is more inland species a wider
distribution based on the occurrences
and also based on our estimated
suitability for the Glovers
okay but that's what we have a visual of
the climatic suitability for the two
Moors but we want to quantify how
different are they really different
these two suitability envelopes so what
we did is we use background similarity
tests which allow us to tell if the two
morphs are ecologically more similar or
less similar than expected by chance and
to do that we create 100 we created 100
replicates of these models where we
randomized one data set for one morph
and created models and then randomized
the other data set for the other model
the other more
and created models so basically we have
real models based on real data comparing
that with random models based on
randomizing taking at random occurrences
not occurrences taking at random
locations that are not presence is for
that particular mode and then we use two
statistics show nurse Janice and I
statistic they basically what they
basically do is they look at the
probability of suitability for one more
and then the probability of suitability
for the other more at each location in
geography and they do slightly different
things but overall they should be quite
they should provide a unified answer if
we get different answers from these two
different metrics it means that we are
not doing something right so the idea
here is quantifying the suitability
probability for each pixel and comparing
between the two morphs so what do we get
what we get is that random this is the
distribution of random models and this
is where our observed overlap niche
overlap or similarity between the two
morphs is so this is number of
replicates obviously we have just one
for the real models and then we have a
number of 100 each for the for the
random models so this is telling us that
Sigma there is a statistical significant
distinction the two marks are less
similar than expected by chance based on
this D statistic we did the same for
this other statistic and we obtained
similar results where the niche
dissimilarity between the two morph were
the tumors were statistically
significant compared to a null
distribution of these or the of these
values okay so what we are saying is the
two morphs are climatically the similar
the one other way to look at this is
which variables contribute most to the
two models the two real models for the
morphs and this is this is the list of
the variables that we used and what we
see is that
involved we have variables that
cumulatively amount to 70% or more
contribution to the model gain of that
for that particular morph
meaning that the variables involved have
the highest contribution the most
important contribution to a good model
fit for that more so what we see is that
there is a discrepancy between glabrous
morph which has the higher has in that
highest contribution means you know
temperature range and temperature
temperature seasonality is very
important but not try comparing and then
going down here we have annual
precipitation and precipitation
seasonality for the other month the try
comparing morph so this tells us that
one morph is more sensitive at least
from this modeling perspective one morph
is more sensitive to temperature
variation and the other one to
precipitation and elevation and minimum
temperature of the coldest month was in
common between the two mores okay next I
would like to talk a little bit about
discrimination of trees and then habitat
structures so going down the scale
moving to finer and finer scales to get
to this these questions now we are
switching to approaches that are based
on remote sensing a very very big field
in engineering in angiography
and we are making use of it just a tiny
bit there's a lot of potential to
develop this field just to get everyone
on board we have some sort of sensor can
be a satellite or can be a on a airplane
and then what the sensor is recording is
the amount of light that is reflected
off different surfaces that the base
that's the basic of remote sensing why
is this important
well for us it's important because it
allows us to get data from above that we
don't get on the ground it is accessible
data if it's satellite collected by a
satellite it's and it's free like
Landsat we have access to that data we
have a greater temporal resolution
because the satellite keeps orbiting the
Earth
so we have a really good temporal
resolution and we do have this potential
in extracting biodiversity data that is
of use to us and just to give you some
ideas we detect certain type of surface
with with remote sensing data so based
on the amount of light reflected we have
different types of two different types
of vegetation and then manmade let's
think of man-made surfaces so the amount
of light that is reflected is basically
what gets used in these land cover
classification if if you look at the
land cover map also very important is
the amount of light that is absorbed or
reflected by different pigments in the
structure of the plant and this is where
remote sensing becomes extremely
important for for us biologists who are
interested in plant function plant
structure plan distribution so this is
the important aspect of remote sensing
now one other important aspect of remote
sensing is that there is a wide variety
of sensors sensors collecting this
information this light amount of light
that is reflected off various surfaces
so a multi spectral sensor splits the
wavelength the electromagnetic spectrum
in a few distinct bands so think of
Landsat for example we have a few
distinct bands the information the
sensor can only process information
amount of light reflected from this one
particular band for example here so
that's multi spectral now hyper spectral
refers to splitting this electromagnetic
spectrum in very narrow bands ten
nanometer bands so we get hundreds of
bands these sensors are provided of data
rich in for ya data sources that are
rich in information okay so one way of
using this is to try to look at
particular reflectance of of different
species and in this case trees so here
the question is can we pick out emergent
trees big large canopy trees that are
standing above smaller trees can we pick
them out spectrally from one of these
hyperspectral high-density of
reflectance bands this work was done in
collaboration with excellent botanist
from from Peru and a field assistant
whose name I forgot and really sorry
this was a long time ago
when I was finishing my PhD so these are
botanists in the field then Greg Gastner
is a scientist at Carnegie Institution
for science and since I have my botanist
collaborators in field mode I pictures I
didn't have them in more official
pictures I decided to go with field mode
for everyone else
so Greg Gastner than my former PhD
advisor and my collaborator from World
Wildlife Fund and this is like I said
work that was finished as I was
finishing graduate school so this had
been published some time ago the study
site was somewhere in southeastern Peru
beautiful areas are also highly diverse
area in terms of tree species and for me
the interest was subset a very small
subset of of these three species that
are used by various animal species as
food resource so forgivers animals that
need resources
what fruit produced produced by these
trees and actually the seasonality which
I will briefly mention so these are the
species of interest we have fabaceae
species here and I forgot the family for
the Brazilian nut I apologize but we
have four taxa from Hebei see and then
the Brazilian nut and then a map of
showing location various points for
these for these species one thing one
thing to notice is low sample sizes
these these are hard areas to work
because they are so diverse the forest
and you can walk and walk and walk and
not find a second emergent Apulia tree
for example so the sample sizes are less
than ideal we also had satellite images
these hyperspectral hide been density
images from four different times and you
notice that precipitation wise we had
dry season more more rain and then the
wettest part of the season of the year
and then another from the dry so we had
both dry more dry and then one image
from the wet season which was quite
impressive and I was quite happy to get
that one because of the cloud cover it's
really hard to get images for for these
regions during the hyperspectral imaging
imagery is exciting but then the
processing is really convoluted I won't
go into it I'll just say that from all
from that great 242 Bend dataset we are
done we were down to 126 that we used
because the various reasons cloud
atmospheric problems poor
signal-to-noise ratio so so quality of
information made us reduce that initial
data set by half of almost and then we
did various things to it I'm not going
to go into it but just I wanted to
mention this 126 bands and just a view
of how this Hyperion Hyperion
hyperspectral imagery maps so we have a
crown here that is almost an entire
pixel 30 by 30 meters another one that
is almost 30 by 30 meters and then we
have a big tree here that is not a full
pixel it is split between four different
pixels so we were focusing on these
pixels that represented more than 40
percent of the crown of a single tree
and then this is a spectral profile with
the bends remove the one the
yeah remaining 126 narrow bands that we
kept in the analysis okay so we did a
linear discriminant function analysis of
these 126 bands we initially be the
stepwise selection procedure procedure
so we we we used only the most
informative of these 126 and we got
really good classification errors
meaning really low classification errors
so what you see is for one tree species
that it's actually a we couldn't
identify to the to the species level so
we use the genus we have for this one
taxon we have classification errors
meaning that the linear discriminant
function analysis was not able to
spectrally identify the individuals that
well but we also had only four
individuals so it's pushing the limits
of this analysis and then for the
Brazilian tree nut we had in one of the
timeframes remember we had four
different images we had we had error
okay and just to show you the two
profiles for for the various individuals
but with this we do see differences in
the these spectral curves we also see
temporal variation within a taxon so
here's a playa in July and in December
different different spectra and that
difference it was quantified with a
canonical analysis so what we see is
that based on the season that these
images are collected the spectral group
in various parts of the canonical space
what this means is we don't have a
spectral signature that is species
specific at all times and we can use
that spectral signature to identify a
tree it is a season based ok lastly the
habitat structure this is going to be
very fast because I don't have a lot of
information we've just started to work
on this and this is with my PhD student
Cassandra who took on this challenge of
learning how to use lidar terrestrial
lidar to quantify a vegetation
architecture for one particular
these bird species that she's interested
in so this is the bird species this is a
general view of the shrubland rasslin
ecotone in Oklahoma and this is what
she's trying to quantify the lidar or
light detection and ranging what what it
does is it sends pulses out and then
measures the time it takes for the pulse
to to reach the sensor again so based on
that if we think of a laser or lidar
that goes or laser a beam that goes from
above this this particular structure
will have this form where there is more
returns when it hits a part of the tree
and less returns when it goes through
between two trees now we can do this
from above but we can do also this from
from the ground and this is where we
where our interest lies for now how can
we do this terrestrial scanning off of
bushes and quantify vegetation structure
and some these are some of the variables
that we hope to take out of this these
clouds of points that we get means shrub
height shrub volume for each foliage
profile yes on the on this this is
distance from the from the scanner this
is how much time it takes for the for
the beam to get back to the pulse to get
back to the to the sensor so it's time
the time is is converted to distance
okay so we don't have any answers this
is what we have we've been doing the
summer collecting data very difficult
logistics we can talk about later if you
are interested but what we are doing is
we are scanning one way and then
scanning another way to get a full 360
view of the vegetation from this point
all the way 500 meters distance and what
we get are for now pretty pictures this
is a point cloud where vegetation is
class
right so we get rid of soil or any other
atmospherics anything that is not
vegetation and this is a profile of one
of the study sites this is another
pretty image so far no quantitative
information but this shows vegetation hi
classified so that the lightest green is
the highest vegetation and the darkest
or the brown air
pixels are the shortest vegetation so we
can get vegetation height for now from
these images okay so what I tried to do
was show you an example at large scale
of ecologic on each modelling of
estimating species richness and what we
see is that at least for the two
families we studied fine scale do not do
this large scale cacti see works better
than Pinay see then moving on to a more
regional scale we compare the morphology
of one species to different morphs and
the potential adaptation to different
environments and what we showed was that
we have two morphs that are climate
statistically they are climatically
dissimilar and then here we were able to
identify trees spectra well trees based
on spectra but there is seasonal
variation so we cannot use one spectral
profile to just go there and and map
species it has to be season specific and
then habitat we don't know yet we are
still in the process of gathering data
and making sense of it but in general
what I want to close with is say that
these types of approaches ecological
niche modeling for example allowed us to
basically extend the amount of
information we can we can gather from
from occurrence data and environmental
data so it allows us to learn a bit more
about ecological requirements climatic
requirements for for particular species
so we hope that this improves our
understanding of species distributions
why species are where they are
and then at fine scale with these remote
sensing approaches what we are trying to
get at is more of the species function
locally and interactions in more of a
habitat plant animal interaction type
any questions this has been a production
of Cornell University on the web at
Cornell edu